- Here's the funny thing, though.
We both have Broadway in common,
'cause we both grew,
well, you have actual Broadway.
And then I just grew
up in musical theater.
- But I love that you love it.
- Very different.
But, my point is I remember
my very first musical
when I was a little kid.
I was like, oh okay, so we're
just gonna break out in song?
We were just talkin',
and then we're just
gonna break out in song?
- Yeah, we call that a Monday
- And then we go back.
- We call that a Monday on Broadway.
- I know, but it's so awkward.
It's a beautiful thing, but I was like,
how awkward is that,
that you just go all the sudden in song.
♪ How can it be ♪
♪ I feel like I have known her forever ♪
♪ Could she be my last
talented and long lost sister ♪
- Oh my gosh, so the crazy
thing though about this,
is now you're in a movie with Scott Wolf
and you're doing the Hallmark thing?
- Yes.
- I love Hallmark Christmas movies.
- Oh my God, and it's a good movie.
Scott Wolfs in it and
his dreamy blue eyes,
and I wrote the title song for it.
You'll love it.
- Oh my, what's the title song called?
- "A Christmas Love Story."
Hallmark, go watch it!
- Oh my God, that's so great.
♪ It all makes sense ♪
♪ I'll never be alone now ♪
♪ She'll always be right here ♪
- Oh my gosh, so tell me about
the Tabernacle Choir thing.
That's crazy.
So you sing with them.
- The tabernacle choir's a right of,
you need to do it, girl.
- You're cooler than me,
let's just get this over with.
- That's gonna happen.
I'll help.
- So how did you get involved with it?
- They asked me to do it,
so I finally took the
opportunity and I got to do it.
and it comes on at Christmas.
- Aw!
♪ I finally found her ♪
♪ Yes you found me ♪
♪ And we'll always be ♪